I'M PASS IONATE ABOUT.
>> YOU SAID YOU CALLED HIM.
THAT MEANS YOU MUST HAVE HIS
PHONE NUMBER.
ARE YOU FRIENDS?
>> WE HAVE BEEN FRIENDS FOR
MANY, MANY YEARS, FOR DECADES AS
A MATTER OF FACT.
>> WHY IS HE SO MEAN TO YOU?
>> WE RUN INTO EACH OTHER IN
PROFESSIONAL WRESTLING.
WE HAVE RUN INTO EACH OTHER --
HE WAS WANTING TO CONTRIBUTE TO
MY CAMPAIGN WHEN I RAN FOR
GOVERNOR.
THE ONLY THING WHY WE DIDN'T
ACCEPT HIS MONEY WAS BECAUSE IT
WAS FROM A GAMING CASINO.
I DIDN'T ACCEPT MONEY FROM
GAMING CASINOS AND FROM
GAMBLING.
AND FROM UNIONS, A CERTAIN LIST
OF THINGS I DIDN'T ACCEPT MONEY.
WE HAD A VERY GOOD RELATIONSHIP.
THE ONLY THING IS, WHAT I THINK
WHAT TICKED HIM OFF IS THE FACT
THAT I DIDN'T VOTE FOR HIM AND
THAT I CAME OUT AND SAID I'M NOT
GOING TO VOTE FOR HIM.
I WOULD URGE OTHERS NOT TO VOTE
FOR HIM.
I THINK THAT TICKED HIM OFF.
THE REASON WHY I DIDN'T -- THE
REASON WHY I DIDN'T WANT TO VOTE
FOR HIM IS BECAUSE JUST ALONG
THE ISSUE THAT HE WANTED TO
BRING COAL BACK.
I SAY, I'VE BEEN FIGHTING FOR
CLEAN ENVIRONMENT SINCE THE TIME
I'VE COME INTO THE GOVERNORSHIP.
WE HAVE TO GO AND CLEANER
ENVIRONMENT.
WE HAVE TO GO INTO A GREEN
ENERGY FUTURE.
WE HAVE 7 MILLION PEOPLE DIE
EVERY YEAR BECAUSE OF POLLUTION.
I TOLD HIM THAT.
THEREFORE, I CANNOT ENDORSE YOU
BECAUSE YOU WANT TO BRING COAL.
THE NEXT THING YOU WANT TO BRING
BACK IS HORSE AND BUGGY OR B
BLOCKBUSTETE